and ea's invested a briefing the company
offered a tease that Mass Effect and
Dragon Age developer Bioware is
expanding beyond role playing games and
could be at work on an action title I'm
Lucy and welcome to your renegade
gamespot news update a slide from the
company's presentation lists fire where
as potentially contributing to ea's
growth in the action category CFO Blake
Jorgensen reiterated previous comments
saying the action genre could be
lucrative in addition to Mass Effect
Andromeda Bioware is working on an
unannounced new IP which if it's an
action game could explain the developers
inclusion on this slide could also be
that Andromeda has expanded beyond the
RPG genre and is now considered an
action game though this is not confirmed
the other developer listed on the slide
under the action category is motive
studios which is overseeing dead space
develop a visceral Star Wars game and is
making its own new IP additionally
titanfall developer respawn
entertainment is working on a
third-person action-adventure game set
in the Star Wars universe also during
the briefing Jorgenson suggested that a
single successful action game could
bring in as much as four hundred million
dollars in incremental revenue with more
upside if and when multiple games come
to market in October last year EA said
it wanted to expand into the Grand Theft
Auto and Assassin's Creed gigantic
action game genre a space that it
doesn't have much of a presence in in
November of that year Jorgensen shared a
few more details on this project
confirming that Jade Raymond the former
Assassin's Creed producer is heading up
one of these games at motive at the time
Jorgensen said we've never really
operated in the largest genre of gaming
and that's the action genre that's the
Assassin's Creed style games more open
world more single play versus
multiplayer it's not been an area that
we've operated in we recently hired Jade
Raymond who is behind the Assassin's
Creed franchise for Ubisoft and she will
be building an action genre for us
through a studio we're building out in
Montreal right now so a lot of
excitement around the action genre
so what do you think bioware secret
project is and will we see it at e3 this
year let me know in the comments below
or come find me on Twitter I'm at Lucy
James games for more on EA's goings-on
keep it gamespot
you